okay everyone I am so excited today
because I am joined by Emily Hampshire
who stars in self-reliance which is on
Hulu now how you doing today Emily oh my
God today is Janu oh yeah January 12th
okay it yes yes in the future we're in
the future right now we're the future
yeah um I'm good I'm good I mean I like
being in the future yeah me too this is
fun um one thing that jumped out to me
about this film is I love that you and
Mary Holland are playing sisters
together in this film um but your
character is named Mary and hers is not
so how confusing was this it was very
confusing thank you for pointing that
out it was very difficult some of the
hardest work I've ever had to do yeah I
could imagine I I did you fight maybe to
see if like hey can I my character at
least be named Mary or or is that or not
Mary I just I just was confused all the
time I didn't even get to make any
argument about it but then I was also
like I couldn't believe that Mary and I
had never played sisters before or that
we weren't already like separated at
Birth because it just feels like it was
meant to be yeah it really does feel
like a real family and you see that a
lot of these films scenes are of you
guys in the character's childhood home
did you become one with the house like
did you pick a bedroom like did you go
to that level oh God why didn't I pick a
bedroom it was kind of not the kind of
other than where we were in the living
room it wasn't the kind of place you
really wanted to pick a bedroom um
but magic of movie making um but no it
did feel like we were a family like
instantly I think that all came from
Jake from the beginning um he brought us
all to his house and we read through the
scenes and just he just gave us all kind
of ownership over our roles within the
family and it naturally felt like we
were all like had lived together forever
yeah and speaking of Jake and his
character of Tommy it feels like a lot
of the family is kind of tough love on
him but I feel like do you maybe think
that your character was the most maybe
understanding deep down of Tommy well I
do I do think that my character think
think that this is the greatest thing
that's ever happened to this family on a
Wednesday like and that's kind of how I
approached it was that it it's hilarious
that that Tommy and to like kind of
stoke that fire and keep it going um so
yeah it was fun yeah and it looked fun
and the movie is just absolutely so much
fun to watch too and you do a lot of fun
things in your life so it's this year
that I got into Jeopardy so I was really
excited to see you on Celebrity Jeopardy
um and what really impressed me was the
video on Instagram you put of preparing
to go on so how rigorous did this
training get for you before you went on
Jeopardy okay Steve so I this is the
what's really embarrassing about
Jeopardy for me is that
I prepared so hard I really thought I
could be a Jeopardy
champion and I bought all the I read all
these books I had like two three weeks
to prepare I learned all the presidents
I because I'm Canadian so I don't know a
lot of American stuff and I learned it
all I believe that I was the worst no
second of the second worst contestant in
all of Jeopardy
history okay so so okay but here's the
Silver Lining you're making history and
all also a President's Rap came out of
it so you made a great song so I think
we have to focus on the positive right
yeah and learned a lot like I've never
learned more than I learned in those two
weeks I learned more than I learned all
of my
education um and my I should be ashamed
of my education after my performance on
the show however I do think there was
certain things that came out of it like
I know one question I supposedly got
wrong was what's the on a quarter and I
said an owl it was bald eagle now if you
look at a bald eagle and an
owl I think it should be changed to Owl
I'm choosing the the better bird
for so so maybe that subconsciously when
you're on it you weren't you were
thinking of things you wanted maybe even
then I want the world as it should be
not as
it okay I got I love that answer um and
you post a lot of fun stuff on Instagram
in general and one that sticks with me
is you were excited about Scott Pilgrim
coming out and I was just trying to
figure out there was so many video game
ciles in that shot there was a PS5 a
switch a classic Nintendo are you a
serious gamer are those your councils
even like what's going on there those
aren't mine okay my best friends and
it's so funny that anytime I post from
there people think I'm way cooler and or
nerdier than I actually am
um I actually really get mad at her
playing video games all the time because
it's it's I'm ignored and I have to just
watch her play video
games so you're calling your friend
nerdy is what you're saying yeah and
we're enraging enraging okay no um
that's cool though but it's also
interesting too because then like I keep
scrolling for par soon if you're just
like enjoying your Instagram videos and
like I see you audition for season 3 so
kind of there people you've left like
waiting for I can't believe you wanted
such a deep dive through my
Instagram so really like that's really
nice yeah but you're leaving us hanging
like have you heard back like we need an
update like is FX reached out or I can't
believe they
haven't I and thank you for bringing
these things up because these are things
that I'm still waiting on yeah and no
one else but you has been paying
attention oh no there's people out there
like there there's a whole discussion
about like your Twitter bio it says I
like Bagels well it's like well what
kind of bagels you know like you're
leaving us I'm from Montreal and those
are the only Bagels is St verer Bagels
oh Bagels should not be called Bagels
they should be called bread that's
shaped round with a hole in it okay so
see this is going back to the Jeopardy
mindset of like what what you want maybe
not what is right yes yes yes okay I
like that now what's also great is you
wrote a graphic novel and it's cool
because it's being released in different
areas more and more um which is really
exciting but do you think you would like
to do more is there more to come is
there like a universe you imagine in
your head oh yeah so my graphic novel is
called Amelia Airwood basic witch and I
um I see an Amelia verse like I I want a
TV show I want a musical it's Matilda
meets Wicked I've already I want more
books I want a prequel and a sequel and
um yeah it was definitely a world that I
wanted to just continue to live in so oh
I love it and you're already thinking of
the merch the everything everything that
can go on spin-offs I love it um and you
know you were in this legendary show as
a legendary character with shitz Creek
and it's a show people play on Loop so
it has that office effect right right so
I'm wondering like do you ever play on
Loop and like let's let's watch self
today kind of thing you ever do that
let's watch self today I love you so
much yeah let's watch so you know what I
hadn't even I remember when the show
first came out and people were talking
about it and I I hadn't seen it I don't
do well watching TV in general that's
not like documentary or murder um but
okay I yeah how ever I do find it
interesting that people come up to me
and say as if it's a compliment I fall
asleep to shits
Creek a lot of people tell me that they
go to sleep to and I'm like that sound
great right right yeah I could see that
taking the other way yeah no but but
it's a good bedtime it makes people feel
good going to sleep it does make people
feel good and that it honestly it is
such a gift to be on a show that people
it makes people feel great and I can't
imagine being on a show that made people
feel terrible because the amount of
great feedback we get would have been in
reverse and I wouldn't want to be on on
the receiving end of that kind of vital
no no but yeah you you only deserve good
things Emily and and it's exciting
because we're going to get more of you
here with self-reliance on Hulu which is
out now because we are in the future I
can't wait for people to join us in the
future and see this Emily thank you so
much for joining me I'll talk to you in
the future one day thank you so much uh
I love you this is so thank you you're
the best I I really appreciate I had so
much fun